[Music]
but I'm here to fix your life what is it
about I wonder you know I'm gonna get
out of this whole [ __ ] comedy
business and I'm just gonna [ __ ] you
know I gotta get into the Joel Olsteen
world I am so [ __ ] envious of that
guy that guy is a [ __ ] genius
he sells out a basketball arena every
single Sunday once a week he does an
arena gig everybody's talking about
Kevin Hart's doing a football say this
[ __ ] guy sells out an arena every
single Sunday that's a tough day to sell
an arena okay
people are hung over from Friday and
Saturday he sells out where the Houston
Rockets used to play he bought that
thing put down some electric blue carpet
and everybody comes to him he sells out
a basketball arena every single week the
same [ __ ] arena he doesn't have to go
on the road you know he's not going to
George W Bush Airport George Herbert
Walker [ __ ] whatever International
Airport right next to Halliburton at now
is called Larry's [ __ ] widgets
whatever the [ __ ] they call it down
there right this [ __ ] just sits
there and he lets the crowd you know
it's he's got his own private Branson
Missouri his own Las Vegas they come
from miles around and they're shiny
pickup trucks their girlfriends named
Darla
right all [ __ ] made-up just an ozone
layer perfume just walk it into that
[ __ ] place and he goes up there right
there's [ __ ] eyes closed you know and
just tells these people what they want
to hear that's the business I want to
get in he doesn't have to pay to rent
the [ __ ] thing out and it's also a
religion so he probably doesn't pay any
taxes he's got his own TV show so you
know he has groupies I mean this guy
were I mean right down the checklist
everybody's talking about Ford verse
Ferrari and what how Ford came up with
this this amazing sports car that beat
Ferrari what about Joel Olsteen versus
every [ __ ] entertainer in this
country you know and you know you got
you Vegas acts that are they're doing a
residency but they don't own the casino
Joel Olsteen went out and he bought his
own flamingo and he headlines it
fifty-two Sundays a year he's got his
own TV show he's got his own radio show
he's like that guy there Ryan Seacrest
except I don't think Ryan Seacrest could
sell out the Staples Center every single
weekend fifty-two Sundays in a row doing
his version of [ __ ] rock and New
Year's Eve in the top 40 there's only
one guy in this country that can do it
that's Joel Olsteen
and I think it's high time when Forbes
talks about the highest-grossing
entertainers out there that they stick
this guy at the top of the [ __ ] list
I didn't think Elvis could [ __ ] play
Houston fifty-two Sundays in a row and
his height treat me like a foo I don't
think I'm oh you never know those same
[ __ ] people would come down there
they go see him on a Saturday and then
all those women's would go down on
Sunday - Joel Osteen's - confess their
sins anyway I don't know so anybody
knows a [ __ ] rundown arena is the is
the [ __ ] the silver dome in Michigan
still available get together with all
things comedy we'll buy that and I'll
just move to [ __ ] Pontiac Michigan
right I'll get an old Pontiac and I'll
[ __ ] drive it in every goddamn week
and I will do my [ __ ] and dick jokes
wearing a suit a little red tie my eyes
closed
and I'll just tell you what you want to
[ __ ] hear huh let me just practice I
got to practice my new Act
we look at you you listening to this
podcast I mean right there you know
you're alive you know you're special you
know that Jesus cares about you
they didn't care about you why would he
give you ears to listen to what I'm
saying to you right now and I'm just a
vessel of his words and it's cold from
up high and it's just passing through me
and it's going right into you it's like
a virus except it doesn't kill you it
makes you live forever praise Jesus
everybody put the hands together put
your hands together everybody close your
eyes so cuz some reason if your eyes are
closed you can't really see the [ __ ]
that's coming at you I wonder feat did
he start like small like how do you
become is it like a preacher open mic
with it just like all right this next
preacher coming to the stage he's a
really funny guy he's been talking about
Jesus up and down the East Coast and it
cultures please welcome Joey Ola Steen
then it comes up there it's Joe Joey
Olsteen but that's okay
he's Jesus forgives Jesus doesn't care
if you call him hey Suze career high
heist he would just deed look the other
way and turn the cheek it's okay I'm
praying for you
why don't you okay that guy over there
hit must have too much of the devil in
him must had a couple of devil dogs when
it came in because the Devils in that
satanic desert and he keep it go for
Joey
Holstein right he bombs for a while then
eventually he just [ __ ] he starts
getting into a groove right I never
forget the first time I was on stage and
I got somebody to say praise Jesus
without asking the crowd to say praise
Jesus and I was like praise Jesus that
guy just said praise Jesus because that
was praising Jesus and it was it was in
that moment I knew that I was on my
weight that I could talk about this guy
who may or may not have existed who may
or may not be hot and I could make some
money first thing I did was I bought an
old Cracker Barrel that went out of
business well you know I started filling
that thing up I want to know this
how did he get to a [ __ ] arena and
the man simply does not have to leave
his [ __ ] ranch every week you know
what everybody everybody goes to Mecca I
figured why wouldn't they come to Joey
Joey Oh lil anestine talking about hey
Suz Kira highest inside an old [ __ ]
arena you know it'd be great what if I
[ __ ] if reunion arena where the
Dallas Mavericks
still used to play right what if that
place still existed what if they didn't
implode that and I bought that okay and
I went against the grain he's down in
Houston and he's praising Jesus I would
go there and I would pray I would go to
Dallas and I would pray Satan you know
but I would steal his delivery right
because I'm evil eye just like Satan
want you to do anything that you want to
do you want to grab a [ __ ] you know
it's good enough for the president it's
good enough for you that's right build
the wall around anybody doesn't look
like us praise praise Satan right now I
would just [ __ ] do that then I'd make
my money and then I could get on TV
shows and Jane Pauley would be
interviewed no but don't you feel the
social responsibility for what is it
you're putting out there I know no I
don't if you look at all all the
commercials on TV they're telling you
they're telling you get that flat screen
they're telling you get that hot tub but
telling you go out there and get that
wakeboard they telling you to go out
there and just have fun fun fun till the
daddy takes the t-bird away no that was
the Beach Boys they're one of the most
wholesome acts in all of pop music
praise Satan Joel Olsteen life story oh
god here we go Joel Osteen's dad was a
Southern Baptist pastor in Texas in
started Lakewood Church oldest I always
wanted you know when you're the son of a
pastor does he make you like go out in
the garage and preach to him you know
until you're like crying and he's just
like you ain't going to bed until you
make me get up out of this chair feeling
that Holy Spirit
this [ __ ] guy just walked by looking
at me like I was a [ __ ] lunatic and
you know what I am [ __ ] screaming
about the Holy Spirit
goddammit headphones and a microphone
all right Joel decide I have to leave
this door open it's hot as [ __ ] in here
sorry enjoy the sounds of traffic joel
decided to go to college but didn't
graduate I like this guy instead he
started the church's television program
it became televising his dad sermons
what we're dealing with here ladies and
gentlemen
is one of my favorite things on the
planet a self-made man he did that for
years until his he's basically the Vince
McMahon of preaching you know Vince
McMahon's dad ran a regional business
Vince took it over and turned it
national turned it into a national thing
anyways he did that for years until his
dad finally convinced him to start
preaching Joel did his first sermon in
1999 shortly after he started his dad
passed away from a heart attack Oh God
Joel took over after that and continued
on the old family business
dude he made it quick he did his first
sermon in 1999 he's had that [ __ ]
he's had that [ __ ] Astrodome whatever
the [ __ ] he bought there in Houston he's
had that thing for 10 years Jesus cried
in faster than a hot chicken showbiz
shortly after he started his dedicate
whatever as you mentioned he purchased
the arena where the Rockets used to play
and renovated it that's [ __ ] great I
think you know you look at goddamn
Atlanta Georgia
that [ __ ] Georgia Dome was fine they
just didn't pull out it and build a
brand new one it's environmental
disaster where the waited way to [ __ ]
did all the trash from the Georgia Dome
go right in the [ __ ] ocean maybe they
saved a couple of beams sold a few seats
it's a [ __ ] joke
now something from Atlanta is gonna try
to defend it you know reportedly these
renovations by the way is there anything
funnier than watching Houston Astro fans
having their backs up about that
cheating scandal I mean they've been
nice to Red Sox fans but if anybody says
the Red Sox cheated on the lazarum
like a [ __ ] absolutely they did [ __ ]
em I don't give a [ __ ] good on them
we're not giving the trophy back
I've reportedly astral French you just
got to roll with it yeah I guess we did
you should try it sometimes ones last
time you won one reportedly these
renovations cost over a hundred million
dollars how the [ __ ] did he afford that
you get a loan and you're a church so
you don't pay taxes so you pay it off
[ __ ] twice as fast cuz they don't
take 50% of your income
anyway he does sell out the arena to
over 50,000 people when he's there that
doesn't hold 50 that doesn't hold 50
it's a basketball arena probably what
the basketball court is about 19,000 you
fill in those [ __ ] seats does he have
people sitting behind him he's selling
anywhere from 20 I would say to about
24,000 anyways he does sell out the
arena arena to over 50,000 people
whenever he's there however he doesn't
always stay there all in caps you were
wrong he and his wife are currently on
tour oh man I wanted him so badly I
guess you got to keep [ __ ] feeding
the flock yeah but for the most part
he's there right even he's talk show
host occasionally they'll go on tour but
I mean they go to the same studio every
day they don't have to go to [ __ ] LAX
but he probably flies private oh man if
Joel Olsteen if you're listening I want
you to pray for my Envy that I have for
you in your show business lifestyle this
is just this man is the greatest and he
kept his hair you know he's just you
know he's in great shape god bless him
he and his wife are currently on tour
they are doing the Toyota arena in
Ontario California get the [ __ ] out of
here in April then they'll be at Yankee
Stadium in May dude I'm goin I'm gonna
go with Bert Kreischer I'm gonna see if
he's around I'm not gonna heckle I'm not
gonna be a [ __ ] I just want to see it
tickets are about 15 to 25 bucks but
when you figure out how many of those
gullible Jesus freaks he packs in there
the high-pitched voice squinty eyed [ __ ]
is going to make a killer good for him
well you know what this bald freckled
[ __ ] is gonna go see him I'll go get him
fifteen to twenty five bucks that Joel
Olsteen Joel Osteen with the power of
the Lord he figured this game out how
did he figure this game out it's the
best it's the it's the best it is the
best you know when he has a very tough
job because all he has is the Bible you
know what I mean I mean I know it's a
lot of pages I know a lot of it doesn't
make sense to the average man but how
many stories can you pull out and
everybody's pulling from the same
[ __ ] you know it's like a stand-up
comedian we got the entire [ __ ]
universe you can pull from this guy just
has the Bible you know what I'd set it
that way on purpose because I'm trying
to give him another subject you know
somebody told me I was talking about me
coming up with pro with sermons and and
and and they were saying I feel bad for
Joel Osteen because all he has is the
Bible let's just think about that for a
second all I have is the Bible I have
the universe in my hand